Je perds la 8ème game
je perds la 9ème game,
je perds la 10ème game,
je perds la 11ème game,
JE PLEURE DE TOUTES MES FORCES !!!
Les amis, aujourd'hui est un grand jour
puisque cela fait maintenant 2 semaines que je n'ai pas joué en classé sur Overwatch.
Tant, la frustration était.. (cri pas virile)TAAH !!!
Mais je me suis entraîné dur en partie rapide,
pour qu'aujourd'hui, devant vos yeux ébahis
*Voix de démon* JE PASSE DIAMANT !!!
Ou alors, j'ai pris mon téléphone comme ça,
j'ai appelé Micka et Alphacast qui ont fait les Worlds d'Overwatch et je leur ai dit :
" Les gars, y'a moyen on s'arrange? " *rire*
Bonjour Alpha, bonjour Micka, comment allez-vous?
[ALPHA] : Bonjour.
[MICKA] : Bonjour
Vous même, vous savez, j'aurais pu passer Diamant seul,
sans aucun problème.
C'est juste que, voilà, je voulais que mes potes bénéficient un peu de mon skill, euh,
je voulais vous faire passer Diamant, quoi.
[ALPHA] : C'est gentil.
[MICKA] : Bah, moi,  je voulais que tu me PL un peu donc ça tombe bien.
Voilà donc c'est euh ... Voilà ... Ah bah oui ! *RIRES*
Les amis, nous n'avons pas joué avant de lancer l'enregistrement de cette vidéo.
Je suis à 2955 de cote. Il faut qu'on gagne 2 games !
Pour que je passe Diamant !
[musique entraînante]
*SILENCE*
Ouais, ça fait déjà 1 minute qu'on attend, ouais.
*MUSIQUE*
Ok les gars, on est sur Gibraltar,
nous devons gagner ! Vous m'entendez ?
[MICKA] : Ah, oui oui.
Ok les gars, c'est parti, c'est parti, c'est parti.
C'est parti ! Let's GO road to Diamant.
Ohhhh y'a une nombor, faites gaffe les gars.
Vas-y je monte à l'étage , je monte à l'étage, je vais leur montrer qui c'est le patron les gars.
Salut les gars, c'est le patron
[MICKA]  : Aller un MCCREE, NICE, REKT
Oh là là là là là comme ça joue bien,
et comme ça RUSH.
Mais on avait pas vu ça depuis les WORLDS. *rire*
Et c'est la folie ça joue extrêmement bien,
c'est d'une beauté incandescente,
ça ne veut rien dire.
Attention, à la Pharah, à la Pharah, à la Pharah
La Pharah est LOW HP
Elle est morte, elle est morte !
... le Reinhardt,
le Reinhardt, le Reinhardt !
Oh là là mais on leur pisse dessus !
Ok les gars en haut à gauche y'a du soldat.
Ça dégage, ça dégage.
Il est très très bon ce Reinhardt!
Très très bon, je l'aime énormément
on atteint le checkpoint
Micka t'es paré ou pas?
[ALPHA]  : Attends moi, attendez moi.
J'vous attends, j'vous attends, on attend la team
OUAIS VAS Y MICKALOW!
Mickaaaa...!
*CRIS D'AMUSEMENT DE SQUEZZIE*
C'est ça qu'on veut!
"What are you gonna do, with my Hanzoo Mickaloo?!"
Alpha : chacun à droite / Squeezie: Y'a le soldier aussi
J'suis sur soldier, il est mort
Micka: j'viens de faire un film de c*l là haut!
*APPLAUDISSEMENTS DE SQUEEZIE*
Bon bah je suis content, on a fait le premier wombo combo
de ma chaîne Youtube
En 5 ans y'avait jamais eu ça ! Faut le préciser
Attendez les gars, j'ai un coup de téléphone...
*pfff haha* trop mal joué ! le mec joue trop mal la comédie
(fait semblant) "Oui allô ? oui bien sûr on le coupera au montage vous en faites pas!"
C'était le CSA il menaçait de mettre la vidéo en -18 si on laissait ce passage
Bah les gars ça commence bien!
C'est pas fini.
C'est normal d'aller aussi vite sur cette map ou pas?
les autres: "non" "non clairement pas"
Bon bah alors on est bien!
Alphacast: là faut reculer!
Faut reculer, au dessus y'a une D.VA
Micka: j'ai peur
Où es-tu Mickalow? Viens avec moi mon chéri
P*tain ils nous pissent à la raie là en vrai hein
Il faut se ressaisir les gars
il faut se ressaisir ils ont mis aussi peu de temps que nous
les gars je joue tellement à ce jeu hors video
que j'ai pas l'habitude de parler en fait quand j'y joue,
c'est un truc de ouf, j'te jure c'est vrai
AlphaCast : Ah le rang Platine expliqué en une phrase.
ho le batard
AlphaCast: J'ai nano-boost la ange
C'est pas mal ça. T'as un nul, t'as un nul. T'es prêt ou pas ?
*Musique épique*
ouiii *rire*
C'est ça qu'on veut ! Comment je suis en train de tryhard.
Mon gars j'ai jamais autant tryhard.
C'est comme si, j'avais envie de prouver aux gens que je méritais d'être Diamant.
Non mais je mérite vraiment d'être diamant. N'ayez pas de doute.
Les gars j'ai mon PC qui me fait des petits lags. Allez 2 minutes 20 à tenir.
Les gars finalement dans une vie c'est quoi ?
Ça commence à blamer le PC.
Non mais c'est vrai ! (Faux)
Merci ça me fait très plaisir. Tu penses que je peux faire les Worlds ?
*rire* (ça veut dire non)
Ok les gars, ça REC, ça REC des gens sur le pont
C'est bien !
ça c'est la résistance ! C'est 1789 !
*rire*
Alpha : Ne meurs pas, ne meurs pas, je vais te heal (soigner)
J'vais mouriiir...
C'est bon, c'est bon, c'est bon.
Aaaah....
Ah ils ont tout lâché les gars.
C'est pas grave ! Il leur reste 39 secondes !
Regarde, regarde le temps qu'il nous reste par rapport à eux. Les gars...
Okay les gars j'suis descendu, j'aurais jamais dû mais je m'en bats les couilles !
Okay les gars j'dois charger pour euh backer ce qui est finalement très humiliant !
Les gars j'vais embarquer quelqu'un. J'vais emmener quelqu'un au poste. Attention !
Monsieur vous venez au poste !
Voooiiilà.
*rire*
C'est bon il leur reste 10 secondes les gars, ils sont finis. Ils sont out.
Ils sont oouut !
Vas-y je vais les empêcher. J'suis devant, j'suis devant !
Et je charge ! Oh merde !
*Musique épique*
Ok les gars, j'ai baisé la Ana. J'suis derrière eux, j'suis derrière eux, j'mets des coups de marteaux, oklm ! J'ulti, j'ulti !
Oh la la ! Oh la la ! Oh la la ! C'est la folie ! Embarquement ! Vous allez au poste ! *Squeezie s'enflame!*
Et c'est la victoooiiire ! *rire*
AlphaCast : On a pas gagné ! On a pas gagné ! *Squeezie frustré*
Excusez moi c'est mes racines de policier là qui ...
Ah c'est pas fini !
Merde faut qu'on fasse wilow
Attends on dirait que je joue avec des randoms là.
Les mecs prennent Genji et Sombra.
Allez les gars, c'est parti vous êtes des flans, tous derrière moi.
Eh ben non, parce que vous allez jouer solo bande de p*tes
Y'a un chacal sur la gauche, sur la gauche, y'a un chacal
Ok les gars, vous assurez j'avoue, c'est très bien, je vois que ça se passe très bien là haut.
Vous leur sautez dessus, c'est hyper sale quoi mon gars.
Ok les gars, je crois que c'est la victoire
On leur a pissé littéralement dessus. (C'est dégeulasse)
Oui *Applaudissement* (Alpha troll Squeezie)
Ah c'est comme ça que tu m'imites ?
Eh ben tu sais quoi?
J'allais dire au gens de te suivre sur Twitch
Eh ben je ne le dis pas.
"Oh c'est Mickalow"
Ca c'est mombo combo
Non, Youtube a dit de le retirer au montage, j'peux pas le montrer.
Oh lala lala, on a fait un bon combo quand même
*Applaudissement*
On en est à combien de cote?
Micka : Moi je dis que t'es pas loin, tu dois être à 80, un truc du genre
Eh ben Micka, Micka tu as gagné
Tu as gagné ce magnifique casque Iron Man
Parce que je suis pile à 80. *Rires*
Oh c'est beau
J'vais chercher à boire
"Qui c'est qui va passer diamant"
*Musique* (Game n°2)
Ok les gars, temple d'Anubi
Moi les gars je reprends mon camionneur, j'reprends mon agent de police
*rire
On a embarqué des voyous
Let's go!
On y ... ok il a voulu m'embarquer
Mais c'est moi la police
C'est pas toi
C'est moi l'agent de police, j'peux pas je prends grave cher, c'est bon c'est bon
J'embarque quelqu'un, les amis et c'est le gros porc!
Micka : Et un p'tit gros pour la table 2. UN
Il s'fait heal
Ok, on le b*ise, on le b*ise, on le b*ise
Allez c'est bon, ça dégage
On avance
Il y a un soldier dedans, je vais tenter une précharge.
Merde j'ai failli réussir, c'est pas grave
Monsieur vous êtes embarqué par la police
Ok, y'a symmetra
Ça dégage
On met du gros coup de marteau
"Allez go, go go go go"
"Combo, c'est parti, c'est parti"
*EN CRIANT* YOOOLOOO !
*Musique épique*
Je m'en bats les c**. On les b*ise tous nous.
C'est la police mon gars
*Musique épique*
Mais ça dégage
Ok les gars c'est pris
Venez, venez on passe à gauche, on passe à gauche
Sombra qui est devant moi
AlphaCast qui s'avance, AlphaCast qui s'avance
Qui va essayer d'en tuer un ou deux dans le fond...
et moi je débarque comme la police
NOPE
Le fourgon s'est fait intercepter
Par une voiture de brigands
J'peux pas le faire
Pourquoi tu l'as pas fait ?
Ah les gars j'ai ulti dans le vent, vous m'aimez ?
*rires*
OMG
Les gars on y va !
*Musique*
Je l'ai eu !
Elle est morte...
Je suis derrière (x2)
Attention je vais mourir, je peux être heal?
*Musique*
Je passe dessous pour récupérer le heal !
Ok, je remonte de l'autre coté j'ai bientôt un ulti les gars !
C'est bon vous les avez chase là ?
Aller on cap ! On cap !
*Musique*
Nice !
Oh ouii !
J'ai ulti une fois que c'est la fin de la game ! Voilà !
Ça reflète bien mon utilité dans cette game !
Je vais jouer Symmetra !
*Rire*
Les gars je vous rappelle que c'est la game qui va me permettre de passer diamant !
C'est celle que j'ai perdue, avec dix autres derrière d'affilée !
*Rires*
J'aimerais vraiment pas que ça se reproduise !
Ok on a une strat !
Mr.Alpha ici présent va ouk quelqu’un qui va se faire ba*ser par mes tourelles !
Faut juste que tu réussisses ton ouk !
Oh ça passe, ça passe de l'autre côté, elle sert à rien notre strat !
Nan c'est vrai ils sont tous de l'autre côté ? Merde !
*Musique épique*
Les gars je suis allé sur le point comme ça, parce que je me suis chauffé !
J'ai tué Soldier !
Oh j'ai failli tuer y'en a un qui a plus de vies !
Mika, Mika, vous le tuez ouuii !
On dirait que j'ai 8 ans et demi dans cette vidéo c'est incroyable !
Les gars je vous mets quoi comme ulti le tp ou le bouclier?
Ok, ok
Le bouclier ou le té, té, tp?
Ok mais faut savoir Mika...
Ok j'mets le TP !
Ok le TP il sert hein, vous savez le tp?
Bah oui ! Le TP c'est...
Nan parce que là du coup je fais vraiment la pire vidéo du monde !
*Rires*
Tant qu'on gagne c'est trop bien !
Je vais prendre la Winstone les gars !
Le point !
C'est pas grave les gars !
Faut que on tienne 3 minutes !
Minimum
Y'a un vieux Lucio de merde qui a trop fait le malin...
Et ça dégage, voilà allègrement !
Moi on m'appelle Miro* dans l' e-sport c'est moi hein.
Tu sors de ton véhicule et tu décèdes immédiatement !
Ahh, ça recule, ça Back hein?
Je leur montre mes doigts de pieds moi, je suis insolent !
Attention Miro s'élance... Il passe en bas, il passe en bas...
Alpha et Micka : Il est où Sensei ?
Oh lalalala, cette...
Ahh, je l'ai tuée mais elle m'a endormi mais je m'en bats les couil*es j'ai eu le temps de la tuer !
Ohh oui, regarde y'a Soldier, Soldier
Hé oui, hé oui c'est ça qu'on veut, c'est le beau jeu !
Est-ce qu'on va mieux faire ? Les gens se le demandent dans la salle !
*Musique épique* Ok les gars, je suis derrière eux (x3)
Allez allez allez !
Ok les gars je gagne du temps vous avez le temps de revenir, vous avez le temps de revenir !
Je les dégage de la place !
C'est bon je l'ai eu!
Ok les gars, je mets des balayettes (x4)
Ohhh, là il m'a embarqué les gars, je suis au poste désolé !
ça sent le gama...
Ah c'est vrai ?!
Ah, put*in...
Ah d'accord... Je prends tout j'ai tout pris !
Aller courage les gars vous tenez, vous tenez !
Mika je te regarde jouer avec ton cow-boy !
Ohhhhhhhh!
Oh ça sent bon, c'est ça l'odeur du diamant?
*Squeezie frustré*
Il a gagné que 15 points il est pas diamant !
Nan ?!
Si !
Espèce de mytho je suis diamant !
*Musique de fête* *Rires*
Ah, l'ascenseur d'émotions !
I'am Diamant, I can pince my tétons easy now!
Eh bien les amis c'est sur cette douce musique de Noël que je vous laisse !
Vous êtes diamant grâce a moi vous êtes contents?
Ouii ! Ahh trop bien !!
Bah voilà c'est mon petit cadeau pour vous les amis !
Franchement la prochaine fois, quand je perds 3 game d'affilée je vous appelle !
Direct comme ça j'ai pas a subir les 11 défaites et la frustration qui va avec !
Pour nous PL, évidemment !
Pour vous PL, oui j'appelle pour vous PL, oui c'est...
Et bah merci à vous les gars on est diamant, on a réussi, je tenais a faire cette putain de vidéo !
Déjà parce qu'elle est sponso et qu'il fallait que je fasse une vidéo sur Overwatch
Et ensuite... *rires*
Parce que ça me faisait marrer de faire l’objectif diamant, EN VIDÉO !
Je vous remercie d'avoir accepté de me rejoindre, n’hésitez pas à passer voir la chaîne YouTube de Mickalow,
Qui a enfin fait une chaîne YouTube,
Et le Twitch d'Alpha c'est ça ?
C'est un homme talentueux !
Il est nul, mais il est talentueux !
Ohhhh ! Je vais vous laisser vous clasher et je vais dire au revoir aux gens !
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu !
Et a très vite, ciao tout le monde